In my Things You Missed episodes on the Final
Destination franchise, I’ve pointed out
some of the hidden signs of impending disaster.
In Final Destination 5, this caution sign
can be seen ahead of the bridge, and what
looks like a simple peeling of plastic from
wear and tear is actually a warning of the
titanic bridge collapse that would follow.
As usual there would be connections to the
disaster that the franchise is based around,
the crash of Flight 180. The bus they are
on is from Rolland Coach Lines. Rolland is
a french name, “that’s a French *** name!”
and the logo features a bird feather, a reference
to flight and the memorial of the Flight 180
crash.
The video that plays inside the bus is from
180 Corporate Consulting, and the bus number
is 1282, the sum of whose digits add up to
13, the unlucky number that we’ve seen arise
in every Final Destination movie.
The main character, Sam, also known as Nick
2.0, sees a vehicle labeled Tagert Logging
Truck No 2. Target is a reference to the Tagert
theater, an accident location in the fourth
movie, and No. 2 is a reference to Final Destination
2, which notably had a huge accident involving
a logging truck just like this one.
And the license plate of this Chevrolet
matches Carter Horton’s car that gets destroyed
in the first movie.
Then, there’s Nathan’s line about his
employee, Roy, which is another possible Death
omen.
“I want him over. Even if it kills me.”
To learn all of FD5’s secrets, including
the clues about the movie’s twist ending,
stick around to the end of this video. This
video is sponsored by NordVPN.
Oh my. Sound the alarm! Alert the media. Because
CZ is actually finishing a movie franchise
he started on Things You Missed.
“I’ve got to make sure that YouTube comes
down to tape this.”
The fifth and final of the original tri-annual
Final Destination movies was directed by Steven
Quale, whose last name sounds like a combination
of a quesadilla and something you would put
on your salad. This is why I should never
write these episodes while I'm hungry. Let’s
get into the Things You Missed.
The story begins outside the offices of Presage
Paper. The word presage is no accident, it’s
defined as a sign or warning that something
(typically something bad) will happen. It’s
also probably no mistake that this is a paper
company, because the boss of Presage Paper,
a man named Dennis Lapman is played by actor
David Kochner, who many will recognize from
his role at the time in the US television
sitcom The Office, where he plays Tod Packer,
who is pretty much the same character as Dennis.
PACKER: “Merry Christmas ***hole!”
MICHAEL: “No way! Ah, you’re kidding me.
Packer! Yes!”
He also seems to have brought himself an Exec
of the Year mug, much like how Michael Scott
has a mug that says World’s Best Boss in The Office.
The license plates also tell us we’re back
in New York, where Final Destinations 1 and
2 took place. Sam and his girlfriend Molly
are having some relationship issues.
“Molly, your ticket’s cancelled. Tell
me that’s a mistake.”
“I was gonna tell you after this weekend.
It’s not working out Sam."
“Well that was a waste of a travel ticket.”
If you’ve seen my previous episodes on the
other movies, you know the drill. Luck, chance
and fate are always referenced in these movies,
because being caught in a disaster is seen
as bad luck, and many of the victims are superstitious.
Candice has a pair of lucky rubber bands.
“Oh it’s just something I do to relax
me. And for luck.”
...and it snaps right before her accident.
The news station that reports on the bridge
collapse is on channel 13, the unlucky number.
The survivors are referred to as the Lucky
8…
“And although they’ve been branded the
Lucky 8…”
Though, eight is not usually considered a
lucky number, as Bradley Donovan can probably
attest to. Isaac steals a gift certificate
for Ming Yun Spa. Ming Yun is the concept
of personal life and destiny in Chinese folk
lore, and before his treatment, he rubs the
Buddha statue’s belly, which is also seen as an omen of good luck. Ironically, it’s
that same statue that winds up being the end
of him.
Olivia also taints her own fortune shortly
before her demise, by knocking over a picture
frame on her desk. More on that later.
The Coach Bus comes up onto the North Bay
Bridge, and we can see it’s a long way down
to the surface.
“Computer generated and animated water.”
Final Destination 5 also brings back the concept
of a recurring Death omen song, Dust in the
Wind by Kansas. This may be a reference to
the tendency of Death to materialize in the
form of a gust of wind. We’ve seen the winds
of Death in relation to many of the accidents,
but perhaps none more than the bridge collapse,
which was said to be the result of high winds
and structural damage caused by the construction.
“They chalk it up to high winds and structural
damage from the road construction.”
“High winds?”
In the scene where the bridge gives way, there
are many undetected clues about how each survivor
would meet their fate. For example, Isaac
dies while laying on his stomach in the premonition,
and he would be in the same position at the
massage place when Death catches up with him.
Olivia’s fate is essentially sealed once
she loses her glasses in the vision, a clue
about her real final moments which are spent
in a procedure to correct her vision. The
premonition shows her surviving the bridge
fall, but ultimately being done in when a
car fall on her. Her actual doom is the opposite,
after her eye is mutilated by the laser, she
does her best Aunt Maggie and falls down several
stories onto a car.
Several characters have to make their way
across a steel beam to get to safety, a foreshadowing
of the balance beam accident that ultimately
got Candice bent over backwards. In the vision,
Candice does fall to her death, which she
technically does in the gym as well.
Peter gets impaled by stakes, just as he is
when Sam skewers him A la Carte and Sam is
chopped in half, much like what happens to
Molly when she’s dissected by the wing of
the airplane. Nathan’s death isn’t really
foreshadowed in the vision, but there would
be a very interesting secret hidden in one
of his time cards.
The holiday season has arrived and you know
what that means. Well, if you're like me it
means horror movies! Just like all the other
months of the year. When you're watching a
lot of horror movies, you may start to exhaust
the selection of your steaming service of
choice. What if you could unlock a bunch of
new movies, just by clicking a button?
With NordVPN, you can do that! I'm gonna use
Netflix as an example. Right now I'm in the
US of A. Literally trapped here, no other
country will accept me. Now, with one, click
I'll change my location. Let's do France in
honor of Final Destination. Look, now we've
got all the movies the French people can see!
You can keep doing this for other countries,
or you can lookup which country you need to
set it to to see a specific movie.
Of course, that's just a benefit of NordVPN.
The main point is to encrypt your web traffic
so that nobody but you knows about the data
you're sending or accessing online.
Now as a CZsWorld viewer, you're gonna be
getting a special holiday deal, where you
get a two year plan with four additional months
free. Just go to http://nordvpn.com/czsworld
and use coupon code CZsWorld at checkout.
The news reports that Presage Paper has 8 survivors,
but the other 17 employees perished in the
collapse. There must have been some people
stowed underneath, because I do not recall
seeing 23 people on that bus.
Surprisingly, this movie doesn’t really
keep up with the tradition of the names of
the deceased being the name of crew members
on the movie. Only two of the last names matches
a name in the credits, and Johnson is one of
the most common American names.
There are two graves in the background, that
be the graves of previous Final Destination
characters. Carpenter could be the headstone
for Nora and Tim Carpenter from Final Destination
2 and Clarke was one of the police officers
from Final Destination 3… although, these
can't actually be their tombstones because those characters haven't died yet.
While the crew reference easter eggs tradition
may have been let go, the tradition of something
wildly inappropriate happening at every funeral
goes strong.
DENNIS: “Or Isaac Palmer.”
ISAAC: “Did he just say my name?
That's not funny.”
OLIVIA: "I know, I'm sorry. I just get weird with tragedies. I'm sorry.”
NATHAN: “I see dead people.”
This is, of course, a reference to the iconic
line from The Sixth Sense.
“I see dead people.”
If you like references to freakin great 90s
movies, this is the entry for you, because
another can be seen later at the office in
the form of these cubicle sticky notes spelling
out “Always Be Closing,” iconic sales
mantra from Glengarry Glen Ross.
“A - B - C.... A - Always. B - Be. C - Closing. Always
be closing, ALWAYS be closing!”
Of course, the most final chapter of the original
pentalogy of Final Destination would contain
a fair share of references to the other films.
When Sam visits Molly, she’s boiling water,
which was part of Valerie Lewton’s death
in the first one; in the gymnastics scene
a potentially electrically charged puddle
creeps towards Candice’s foot like the puddle
in Tod Waggner’s bathroom; Sam’s cubicle
has a toy motorcycle, similar to Eugene’s
motorcycle in FD2, and the motto “Born to
Ride” references the opening of each movie
which all feature disasters during a ride
of some kind and Isaac flirts with a girl
on the phone named Kimber,
"Tell me it's the Kimber from last Tuesday."
this could have maybe been Kimberly Corman from Final Destination
2.
Also, this has nothing to do with the story
at all, but did anyone notice as Sam is getting
out of work, there’s this truck just completely
bastardizing the parking job? I mean, that
person is almost completely up on the curb,
what the hell?
Speaking of hell, there are usually a lot
of references to Hell or the devil in relation
to deaths. I think there’s only one new
one in this movie. It comes when the rogue
factory guy Roy fails to take Mr. Krabs’s
warning into account…
“They're back! They're back I tell ya! The hooks! The hooks!”
...And gets himself Bobby Dagened right through
the skull. The end of “the hook!” pokes
through the top of his skull like a devil’s
horn. After seeing this, Peter is very…
shall we say… curious, about the circumstances
of the accident.
PETER: “Did you or didn’t you?”
SAM: “Hey Peter, calm down--”
PETER: Did you or didn’t you? Did you or
didn’t you?”
DID YOU OR DIDN'T YOU?!
NATHAN: “Yes. I think I did.”
I never understood why he would say that.
Anyway, the first tragedy after escaping the
bridge is Candice’s gymnastics mishap. She
speaks with her boyfriend before going on,
and walks out from Section 108 in the stands,
an anagram of the cursed flight number: 180.
Earlier I mentioned the wind being a symbol
that Death is among the characters, and we’ve
seen it in many forms in the series, starting
with the fan in Alex Browning’s bedroom. In
the gymnastics scene, we see a fan brought
in because the air conditioning is broken
and it contributes to taking out Candice.
Another bad sign that can be found in the
scene is an AC plug, which looks kind of like a skull.
The ambulance that shows up is U1575. U is
the 21st letter of the alphabet, so if you
add that to the other digits, 1+5+7+5, you
get 39, which matches the amount of Mt. Abraham
High School students who pass away on Flight
180.
The next day at the office, not that The Office,
some of the remaining Presage employees return
to work. In each movie, I’ve mentioned how
the character names correspond with filmmakers
who had an impact on the horror genre. It’s
here we find out about a few more.
Olivia Castle is named after the great William
Castle, Peter Friedkin after the great William
Friedkin, and Candice Hooper after the great
Tobe Hooper. Olivia’s eye doctor is named
Dr. Leonetti. This may be a reference to John Leonetti a notable horror movie cinematographer
horror films than a director that would go
on to direct five horror films in a row after
this. Isaac Palmer was named after Betsy Palmer
who is most well known as Pamela Voorhees.
Isaac does some snooping around the office
and steals a gift certificate from his late
co-worker. The expiration date is
6/30/01. If we
multiply 6x30x1 we get the number that’s
come up time and time again: one hundred seventy
nine. I’m just kidding. It’s 180.
The certificate number also ends in 810 which
is an anagram of 180. Isaac hurts his finger
while retrieving it, just as Sam did on the
bus and on the plane, meaning that this would
be a sign that Isaac’s hours are numbered.
Nathan brings up a case of adult beverages.
If you watched my other Final Destination
videos, you already know what’s coming.
It’s a 6-pack of Hice Pale Ale, the fizzy
but fatal refreshment that foreshadowed disasters
in the last 3 Final Destination movies.
But the office would contain another important
Final Destination callback.
FD5 lacks the volume of crew reference easter
eggs that the other movies have, but I did
spot one more in the Presage office. In Olivia’s
work area, there is a memorandum to the board
of directors from Adrian Hrydak. He is Final
Destination 5’s graphic designer.
I already mentioned Olivia’s broken picture
frame, but what I didn’t bring up is the
photo itself. It’s a ride photo from Devil’s
Flight, the roller coaster that would crash
5 years later during the events of Final Destination
3. They claim it’s the World’s Scariest
Roller Coaster. The movie is set in 2000 about
2 weeks before Millenium Force would open,
but I’d still probably have to give it to
Oblivion at that point in time.
The next death is Isaac’s at the massage
place. “Yum yum dim sum!” And the only
other thing I’ll say about this is that
the no cell phones sign seen in the lobby
may count as an actual warning from Death,
considering that his phone is actually what
causes the fire.
After that is Olivia, at the Eastfield Laser
Eye Center, and her sign comes when she’s
squeezing the teddy bear for comfort and it’s
eye pops off. The same happens to her not
long after. Out of every scene in the franchise,
I think this is the fatality that affected
me most.
Sam recalls his vision to try to remember
the order that they were supposed to die in,
where we see, probably my favorite part.
“AHHHHHH!”
Why did they do that? Don’t they know that
slowing stuff down makes it funny?
“AHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH!”
The next death is supposed to be Nathan, who’s
still having problems with an employee named Roy.
He does a little snooping, using security
camera 32, the reverse of 23, as in Route
23. Also, just gotta say, for a security camera,
that definition is ****ing incredible. Look
at that. Most security cameras you can barely
even see Faze Bank’s bald spot, but on this
thing you can zoom right into the hairs on
Roy’s chin.
I gotta get me a camera like that. The DX8100.
It’s probably another anagram of the flight
number 180. With an extra 0 tacked on.
The finale involves Peter coming into the
restaurant that Sam works at to take Molly’s
life so that he can theoretically add her
years to his own. Don’t get me wrong,
I love this scene. It’s very satisfying
to have an actual antagonist in these movies
after nearly 5 movies. I just think the way
it all goes down is kind of hilarious. He
just invites himself in, pours himself a huge
glass of wine and then goes all Badlands Chugs
on it.
And then Peter chases them into the kitchen
and… what, why is he turning on all the
fryers? Is he planning on deep frying Molly?
This is gonna be the best kill ever.
WHA! Do! It! Do! It!
As you may know, two thirds of all Final Destination
deaths are involve water or liquid. I think
this comment on my FD4 episode puts it best.
“Water is the source of life on this planet.
Without liquid water, we would not be here.
It is fitting that a liquid starts all the
death.”
The movie started when The North Bay Bridge
collapsed into the water. Candice’s final
college practice would become her final ever
practice thanks in part to the dripping water
from the air conditioner. Isaac didn’t exactly
get his happy ending massage, because the
bottle of disinfectant alcohol falls, starting
a typical Final Destination flammable liquid
incident. Olivia’s fun and games end when
her water, or rather, her Woda, spills onto
the outlet, causing the laser surgery machine
to malfunction. Sam and Molly’s plane crashes
into the Atlantic Ocean, and Nathan meets
his fate at a bar.
Of course, whenever I talk about Final Destination
5, people tell me how they were blown away
by that twist ending. Pun slightly intended.
Five was actually my first Final Destination
movie, because my friends told me you don’t
have to watch them in order. LIARS. So I had
no idea what was going on when they boarded
Flight 180 at the end, and I was kinda pissed
when I found out that it was ruined for me just so we could watch that movie that night.
But upon rewatching, I noticed at least 9
different signs, some of which may be kind
of obvious, that Final Destination 5 was in
fact a prequel, not a sequel.
I’ll start with the opening credits. They
contain a montage of the other disasters we’ve
seen in the franchise, and when Flight 180
blows up, it emits this metal beam in a V-shape.
V is the roman numeral for five. Final Destination
5 would contain Flight 180.
We’ve got to take into account the title
of the lasts movie. It would be a bit strange
to make a movie called The Final Destination,
only to follow it up with a sequel a few years
later. However, making FD5 a prequel allows
The Final Destination to remain The Final
Destination chronologically.
Sam is an aspiring chef, and the next clue
comes when he reveals that his restaurant
wants to send him to an apprenticeship in
Paris.
“They want to send me to the flashship restaurant
in Paris for who knows how long?”
Flight 180 was a trip to Paris, France. The
restaurant he works is Le Cafe Miro 81. This
is the very same name as the restaurant whose
dislodged sign took out Carter Horton at the
end of the first Final Destination. Had he
ever made it to that job, he would have been
working at that very same restaurant.
Then there’s the return of William Bludworth.
I went more into detail on this in my Horror
History episode on Bludworth, but basically,
he stops showing up after Final Destination
2, so his presence may suggest that we’re
actually in the past.
More evidence that we’re at the dawn of
a new millennium can be found in the gymnasium
at Westdale College where recent looking championship
banners are hanging from 1994 and 1998, but
nothing past the year 2000.
Then in the office, there are a couple of
clues. The first is more of a bad omen. A
miniature model of the Volée aircraft can
be seen sitting on the cubicle walls, and
when Isaac steals Robert’s spa certificate,
the expiration date can clearly be seen: it’s
in 2001, and when he tries to use it, it works,
implying that 2001 has not yet arrived.
Later on, in Nathan’s office, we see the
actual date as he’s collecting time cards
for the week ending in April 30th 2000. This
is just 2 weeks before the date of the Volée
Flight 180 crash, which took place on May
13th, 2000 in the sequel universe.
As I’ve discussed before, there are two
continuities. In the original, the crash takes
place in 1999, in all the sequels, it takes
place in 2000.
“I have thought a lot about that somewhere Alex. It exists, that place.”
So the day of the flight arrives, and Sam
and Molly take their seats in Row 23, there’s
that number from FD2 again.
I did go back to the first movie to see if
the people sitting in those seats resembled
Sam and Molly at all. They don’t. There’s
a brown haired man in Molly’s seat and a
brunette woman in Sam’s. Which begs the
question: why didn’t they just cast character
who look like these, rather than cast someone
who looks exactly like Nick from the last
movie? None of the other passengers resemble
the passengers from the original Flight 180,
for example, this is where Billy Hitchcock
should be.
Actually, there are a lot of inconsistencies,
like how the plane is now 1 row shorter than
it was in the first movie. Or how the gate
number on Sam’s travel ticket is H6, but
we clearly see it’s Gate 46 in the first
movie. He’s seated in 23J. According to
the way the seats were mapped in the original,
he should actually have 23B.
These could be seen as mistakes, and they
may be, but these small changes can be explained
away with this idea that the sequel universe
changes little details from the original.
The final signs for Sam come too late. He
once again hears the Death omen song from
the opening, Dust in the Wind, and Molly’s
magazine has an ad for Eastfield Laser Eye
Center where Olivia died. You’d think the
ensuing malpractice suit might have gotten
them shut down.
The final scene shows the final survivor,
Nathan, attending the memorial for Roy. Dust
in the Wind can be heard playing in the background…
🎵 Nothin' lasts forever but the earth and sky 🎵
...and in one of the photos on the shrine,
we see that Roy is a fan of race car number
6, the car that causes the big speedway accident
in Final Destination 4.
There’s another FD4 reference, when this
guy tells Nathan that Roy didn’t have long
to live anyway.
“Life’s a b****.”
We saw this same phrase on the back of someone’s
shirt at the race track.
Finally, before the franchise would be laid
to rest for the next decade, they just had
to squeeze in one last Hice Pale Ale logo.
There has been talk of a Final Destination
6, and I’m going to be doing a video breaking
down the possibilities for that new sequel.
So, make sure you’re subscribed to CZsWorld
for new horrors every week, ring the deathbell
for notifications, and I will see you in the
next one. Assuming we both survive. If you
want to beat Death, use a facemask and social
distancing.